foreign
in the mid-1930s two familiar spiers
towered above the morning fog stretching
227 meters into the sky these 22 000 ton
Towers would help support California's
Golden Gate Bridge
but since they were currently in
Pennsylvania they first had to be
dismantled packaged and shipped piece by
piece over 4 500 kilometers away
moving the Bridge's Towers across a
continent was just one of the challenges
facing Charles Ellis and Joseph Strauss
the Project's lead engineers
even before construction began the pair
faced all kinds of opposition the
military feared the bridge would make
the important Harbor an even more
vulnerable Target Ferry companies
claimed the bridge would steal their
business and residents wanted to
preserve the area's natural scenery
worse still many Engineers thought the
project was impossible the Golden Gate
Strait was home to 96 kilometer per hour
winds swirling Tides an endless blanket
of fog and the earthquake-prone San
Andreas fault but Strauss was convinced
the bridge could be built and that it
would provide San Francisco's commuters
more reliable passage to the city he was
however a bit out of his depth
strauss's initial plans to span the
strait used at cantilever bridge this
kind of bridge consists of a single beam
anchored at one end an extended
horizontally like a diving board since
these Bridges can only extend so far
before collapsing under their own weight
strauss's design used two cantilevers
linked by a structure in the middle but
Ellis and his colleague Leon moyesife
convinced Strauss to pursue a different
approach the suspension bridge where a
cantilever bridge is supported from one
end a suspension bridge suspends its
deck from cables strung across the Gap
the result is a more flexible structure
that's resilient to winds and shifting
loads this kind of design had long been
used for small rope Bridges and in the
1930s Advanced steel manufacturing could
create cables of bundled wire to act as
strong steel rope for large scale
construction at the time the Golden Gate
Bridge was the longest and tallest
suspension bridge ever attempted and its
design was only possible due to these
Innovations but cables and towers of
this size could only be built at large
steel works on the country's East Coast
while the recently completed Panama
Canal made it possible to ship these
components to California reassembling
the towers on site didn't go quite as
smoothly it was relatively easy to find
a stable shallow foundation for the
North Tower but building the South Tower
essentially required erecting a 10-story
building underwater since the Strait's
depth prevented them drilling or digging
the foundations bombs were dropped on
the ocean floor creating openings for
pouring concrete a Seawall was built to
protect the site from powerful currents
and workers operated in 20-minute shifts
between Tides the towers had so many
compartments that each worker carried a
set of plans to prevent getting lost and
at one point an earthquake rocked the
South Tower nearly five meters in each
Direction
Strauss took worker safety very
seriously requiring hard hats at all
times and stretching a safety net below
the towers but not even these
precautions could prevent an entire
scaffolding platform from falling in
1937 carrying 10 workers to their deaths
once the towers were complete workers
spun the cables in place hung suspenders
at 50-foot intervals and laid down the
concrete roadway the bridge was finished
but there was still one more task ahead
painting it after production the steel
had been coated with a reddish paint
primer it maintained throughout
construction but the Navy had been
pushing hard to paint the bridge a
tactical Black and Yellow
Consulting architect Irving Morrow
actually thought the primer itself
paired nicely with the Strait's natural
backdrop and he wasn't alone citing
numerous letters from locals Morrow's
30-page pitch to paint the bridge
International Orange beat out the Navy's
plans and today this iconic color still
complements The Straits Blue Water Green
Hills and rolling fog
travel cross country to the east Coast's
most iconic Skyline New York City it
took nearly two decades over 400 million
dollars and 6 000 kilometers of wire to
complete the Brooklyn Bridge find out
more about one of history's most epic
Feats of engineering with this video